first up bill de blasio our wonderful
mayor of New York City dropped out I
know you you're stunned by this but of
the presidential race
he was polling at around zero percent on
a good day once in a while he was at 1%
president Trump of course not missing an
opportunity to have a little fun with
all of this news watch this I see that
our part-time mayor will be now going
back to New York so they'd be able to
work a little bit harder but he dropped
out of the presidential race a little
while ago too bad he had tremendous
potential he only had one real asset you
know it was hi nothing going so he's
worried about the work schedule I think
in in May or June he worked about seven
hours I believe over the course of that
he takes his SUV to Brooklyn because he
likes to go to his old gym all the time
and then he's talked to a lot about
about climate change but it didn't work
but he's gonna come back and fix New
York now you know I think the big truth
is that his absence wasn't missed if
anything traffic moved better when he's
not here and the lesson is being mayor
of New York City is way easier than it
looks
if this dope can phone it in think about
it you got a huge tax base you have a
bottomless supply of tourists and
tourist dollars you have a superior
police and fire department the mayor
should just leave town permanently we'll
be fine
I just like the fact that in a couple
years Trump still going to be president
he won't be mayor anymore
that is sweet justice and one of the
things that we really don't appreciate
this president for one is he really
knows how to kick people when they're
down
[Laughter]
and that score Jesse's right but I do
think that says more about Trump that
he's gonna kick this guy when he's down
then it says about the mayor he can go
back to smoking pot and drop in
groundhogs and that's all he's good for
Trump can go back to what is it like he
doesn't go up she'll go show up or work
in the Oval Office before noon more
personal time he and de Blasio could
hang out executive time I'm not really
quick I got a long memory so I
appreciate I'll wait years to kick you
when you're down by the way he's a
living breathing example de Blasio as of
how socialism fails fails those most in
need and the Democrats need him gone
they're gonna have a problem trying to
explain their ideas with him around